this is how it all went down there's a
pseudonymous Twitter poster name that
calls himself James Medlock uh describes
himself as a tax Enthusiast and
hyperinflation doubter and says I bet
I'll bet anyone one million dollars that
the U.S does not enter hyperinflation
that of course being a sort of joke in
itself in that if it went to if we had
hyperinflation the million dollars
wouldn't be worth so much but abology
you jumped in and said I will take that
bet you buy one Bitcoin I will send a
million US dollars in a sense this is a
bet that I've already won and I bet that
I've already lost all right why okay so
the point was to bring attention to the
stealth financial crisis that uh at the
time that I tweeted this that had not
been acknowledged as such
um people were treating it as an
isolated bank failure they were trying
to say that the FED had nothing to do
with it they were trying to say that oh
of course everybody knows how to hedge
um duration risk and it was just you
know one dumb bank manager uh people
were not talking about the fact that the
crypto exits were being closed with
crypto Banks getting shut down and
crypto companies getting assaulted and
so how do you punch through that right
how do you how do you go like you know
you have CNN you have Wall Street
Journal and like the Washington is
reporting on this some somewhat but
they're reporting it on a as a like a
blow by blow basis like this bank is
going down and this thing has a problem
as opposed to an overall narrative that
puts the facts together in a different
way which says the FED actually killed
the base
um and uh and that's actually the
updated engine firefighter right
and uh and that gives a model of what to
expect so Point basically being how do
you punch through that cycle and I
actually a few days earlier had a a
different thing where I was just
basically paying people like a thousand
bucks to post about
um you know like like graphs and charts
on this stealth financial crisis and
then mocking that headlock came and he
was like oh and the US will never enter
hyperinflation and so then I was like
okay fine you know why don't we why
don't we take this a little little bet
because I had already set out to
essentially burn money as a public
service to alert people to the self
financial crisis this was the post that
I wanted people to see
okay it's a reply to the bed post and
essentially lays out a completely
different narrative than well you'd read
in the Press where you you know insofar
as you if you're if you're to believe
Twitter before this
um some immigrant engineer in Sunnyvale
is responsible for finding a hidden
insolvency in a footnote of a bank 10q
but Jerome Powell is responsible for
nothing
that's literally what the narrative was
and I knew hundreds of like Indian
Founders other Founders who are like I
don't trust U.S banks and moving their
money back home just getting their money
the heck out not knowing what the hell
was happening just knowing they were
getting lame for the bank losing their
money
and pulling it all together essentially
just as in 2008 the bankers live this
time the central Bankers the banks and
the bank Regulators have lied to all
dollar holders and depositors not your
typical fractional Reserve situation
there isn't enough in the banks on a
mark to Market basis cover withdrawals
they knew this all through last year and
communicated internally in their coded
language I give a bunch of citations the
keyword is unrealized losses citations
to the FED citations FDIC citations of
banks themselves visitations to the
banks accountants showing them how to
hide the insolvency I'm not selling any
Bitcoin
um holding Bitcoin until the U.S dollars
no longer Reserve currency because the
delegation would be that you own a lot
of Bitcoin so you're trying to pump up
the price to make more than the one or
two million dollars that you've bet yeah
exactly that's his allegation which is
false and I've rebutted it publicly
um first obviously schools have had
Bitcoin forever but second is I didn't
actually even propose this bet I adapted
it right it was somebody else who
proposed it and so on like they're
poking at me
um third is that uh this is like a Simon
erlich cell event it's like 90 I can't
actually make you know money on it it
was meant to prove a point about this
financial Crest and you can see my state
of mind if you go and look at the tweets
since like March 11th like essentially
we're gonna do these piecing together at
this end that I just kind of described I
was trying to figure out what the heck
I'm looking at real estate Bank okay so
it's a sorry so it's a you're saying
it's a Julian Simon Paul Ehrlich style
bat who famously made a bet trying to
see you know uh you know Ehrlich was was
predicting that we're going to be
overpopulated and commodity prices are
going to go crazy Julian Simon said no
let's bet on this basket of Commodities
and Simon famously won that bet so he he
actually believed that this was not
going to happen and he won the the bet I
guess that's the one question I want to
get to you before we have Larry weigh in
here is like do you actually believe
Bitcoin is going to a million dollars or
is it really just to draw is it like a
you know drawing attention to this
problem that you've laid out I think
Bitcoin will eventually go to a million
dollars
um I do think there are some Pro Arthur
Hayes also thinks it's going a million
like basically I think we're now in the
the final stages of Fiat in a sense like
they've realized that they cannot
um they tried this rate hiking thing
they buckled now printing again so we're
in like and we're all in a base of high
Invasion and unlike 2008 the US dollar
is no longer too big to fail like it has
two scale competitors in the form of BTC
and R B and God help us if r b if they
open the capital account in China is a
nuclear currency then we're all under
some horrible surveillance team even the
dollar itself is being turned into
something pretty terrible I think with
this fed now thing which is not
technically a cbdc but it's got many of
the negative aspects of CPC for civil
liberties so
um so you know the thing is timing is
timing is hard prepping is easy okay so
I don't know exactly when this is going
to happen but I wanted to draw attention
to the combination of a lot of small
Banks being destroyed with money being
centralized in in big Banks or money
market funds B the crypto exits being
closed C an enormous amount of printing
beginning and then D it emits all of
this in July push up the timetable
evidently for the FED Now launch we
should make it easy to impose Capital
controls and lock you in to a system of
potentially devalued dollars let me play
uh a clip from uh Fed chair Jerome
Powell expressing a contrary opinion
about the state of the banking system
and then Larry I'd like you to weigh in
and tell me you know do you side more
with Balaji do you side more with pal or
do you have a totally different take on
all this
system is sound and resilient with
strong our banking system is sound and
resilient with strong capital and
liquidity
we will continue to closely monitor
conditions in the banking system and are
prepared to use all of our tools as
needed to keep it safe and sound
what do you think Larry
no I think I'm on biology side when it
comes to the soundness of the banking
system or lack of soundness of the U.S
banking system and I think he's doing a
real service by drawing attention to uh
what's been going on
now I don't follow uh that
hyperinflation is going to be the result
of it uh
but yeah the the banking systems in in
very deep trouble
and it's because of Central Bank policy
and even if the FED hadn't tightened
monetary policy there would have been a
problem
because the loose monetary policy that
the FED ran during the pandemic and then
didn't
withdraw when uh the need for
that much liquidity was had vanished
uh gave us the 8.9 inflation that we had
last year the FED is itself is already
solvent
it's worth mentioning the FED itself has
a very long Bond portfolio and it's lost
enough money to wipe out its capital
uh but that doesn't stop them
in a Fiat money system nobody can redeem
their liabilities so they can keep on
printing they can keep
employees and they can keep on lending
to Banks
but they don't need to engage in a hyper
expansion in order to lend more to Banks
and even if they lend more to Banks and
don't neutralize the effect on the
monetary base they can neutralize the
effect on money held by the public so it
depends on whether the FED will take
those steps
and it if they're at all serious about
keeping inflation contained they will
have to take those steps now that we've
seen in other countries the kind of
problem where central banks issue a
blanket guarantee that they're going to
print enough money to save all the banks
the Philippines did that in 1997 and the
result was inflation and a sharp
devaluation of the Philippine currency
but in the U.S we bailed out the Savings
and Loan industry without that causing
an inflation in fact that happened in a
period of falling inflation
so I'm skeptical of the prediction of
hyperinflation in the U.S and
correspondingly I'm skeptical of hyper
bitcoinization as a result
uh let's talk let's talk first about
hyperinflation what what do you say to
that skepticism apology
so the thing is that actually I'm trying
to find this paper I mean there's a
difference between hyperinflation and
Hyper bitcoinization those are actually
distinct and it's actually possible for
people to have something like uh you
know what happened to Argentina where uh
you had both a massive economic
contraction and massive and uh the
dollar tripled in value
um like relative to so people were
trying to the the economy was
Contracting and people were trying to
exit it at the same time for a stronger
at the same time that is what like hyper
bitcoinization looks like where
um you know you could potentially even
have some prices fall or you could have
weird things happening where like I
don't know housing crisis fall and food
prices rise or things are all just
Haywire because they've broken some of
the normal relationships where they're
still hiking rates but they're then
bailing out the banks while they're
hiking rates normal relationship between
High rates and type munchers has been
broken so just like sagflation is in
like a region of of the graph where you
think that you know inflation
unemployment are traded off but maybe
they could happen at the same time
um I don't know whether typical economic
relationships will will hold so I don't
have a strong thesis on all the internal
dynamics of the US or more generally
Western economies I do think that more
and more people will want to exit them
and that's that's what
hyperbitronization means hey thanks for
watching and excerpt from that
conversation with Balaji srinivasan and
Lawrence H white about balaji's million
dollar Bitcoin bet the state of the
banking system and the US dollar you
could watch the full conversation here
or another clip here